how do you find the right people I've
got a great two-part question from a
YouTube viewer
JGI G 72 84 this is gonna be great
learning tool for you guys if you're
thinking about hiring people so the
first part of his question was how do I
find people to to work with me and if
they say no should I just go it alone
and not try to get anybody and the
second part is if I then become
successful and they want to come back
should I accept them or not so first of
all before you even think about bringing
on a team before you even think about
starting this business have a solid
purpose and a reason for being in
business why are you starting this
company it's so important it's
everything it's not just to make money
it has to be something else money will
get get people's hours to get their time
but you won't win the heart and their
soul and you need to have that in any
business so in my business I love
helping entrepreneurs that's what I'm
all about I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I do a lot of stuff for
free like these videos because it's my
passion I want to see you be successful
I love entrepreneurs and everybody I
bring on has to love helping
entrepreneurs as well they have to
believe in what this business is all
about so the first part of your question
if you're talking to people trying to
convince them to come on board if they
don't have that same belief then then
they shouldn't be a part of your team
but you have to know there are people if
you have a powerful vision for your
business there are people who would be
honored to work with you who have been
searching who've been in crappy jobs
their whole life looking for a company
that stands for something that has
meaning to work for because most people
hate their jobs 90% of America gets up
every day and goes to a job that they
hate so if there's an opportunity to
work with somebody who stands for
something
and stands for something that they
believe in they're gonna be all over it
so there are people who want to say yes
to you the people at my business I pay
them but they would work for me even if
I didn't pay them because they love
this business stands for what does your
company stand for there has to be
something special you don't want people
only to come for you because you're
paying them well or you're paying them
something there has to be a greater
purpose so know that there are people
out there and it starts with you
identify that passion identify the
purpose of what you're doing in your
company and there are definitely highly
talented skilled people who want to
partner up and work with you
the second part of should you accept
people who you ask to join you but they
said no should you accept them back into
your business later once you become
successful this is a no brainer for me
why would you want somebody in your
business who said no to you before who
didn't believe in what you were doing
and said no and now what they suddenly
believe in your company that's BS I
don't want people on my team who do not
want to help entrepreneurs who don't
believe in what we're all about
because those people won't last if
somebody's there just for the money or
just for the opportunity they're not
gonna last you want the people who
strongly believe in your core and they
would join you if you're at the startup
stage or if you're well established if
somebody says no to you because they
don't believe in what you're all about
then you should never bring that person
on board you could be friends you know
it doesn't have to be personal I've I've
hired and fired my best friend than my
business and we're still friends so you
don't have to make it personal but that
guy is never gonna come back and work in
my business and if people say no I don't
want to join you they should never be
allowed to join you you missed out and
now that we're successful you want to
come back on board not happening you
have to be in this for the right reasons
and if you don't believe in what we're
all about then you go find something and
it's good for them right if somebody
doesn't want to work with me they have a
different passion and that's cool I
don't want to force you to work in my
business that you're not excited about
go find something that you love doing
something that you believe in go make
your mark with a different business or
start your own
that's good that's good for me and it's
good for you but it all starts with that
core purpose and vision for your
business and communicating that so it's
extra super clear to everybody in your
business and it's your it's not just
your employees it's your employees as
your partner's as your investors it's
your suppliers
it's your customers it's the media
everybody has to understand and it gives
you such clarity it makes decisions so
much easier for you once you can build
your business around that passion core
purpose believe if you guys liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes you want to do more for
you and I love to hear what you have to
think please leave a comment underneath
let me know your thoughts let me know
your questions I'll do a video response
thank you so much I'll see you soon